well braves country my partner just set
a land speed record not only did he
participate in the pre-game parade for
alumni weekend he caught the ceremonial
first pitch from chipper jones and has
made his way to the booth big ovations
for chipper and frenchy as we get the
night off to a great start at truest
park
he's a hall of famer man what are you
going to do
[Applause]
we got a great matchup right out of the
box ian anderson against adam frazier
who had four hits last night jeff ian
anderson at home has been great he's
been great all year need him to go deep
in this game and let the braves offense
go to work he's been kind of the horse
in this rotation last five starts he's
streaming one with a 2-4-3
and the first pitch of the night is
bunted kevin smith debuting for the
braves throws to first and not in time
it's a bunt single
adam frazier has his fifth hit against
atlanta in a game plus and that's how
game two starts a bunt for a base hit
and polanco swings through 95 up around
his eyes fastball after fastball and
polanco is the second out
and it's chopped toward third riley's
got it throws on the run
anderson gives up back-to-back hits and
then the pirates can't get the ball out
of the infield the braves right-hander
off to a good start so are we here tyler
anderson
yeah i mean that's hard to tell a
pitcher not to throw first pitch strikes
me three 350 the era just about a
strikeout per inning
ozzy's over his last 16. the 3-2
swing and a shot headed for the gap
that's gonna work that ball is off the
base of the wall a run is in ozzie's at
second and the braves strike with two
outs in the first there we go
that's how you break it over
and that ball jumped off his back
[Applause]
and he gets
the strikeout does tyler anderson but
the braves score first and have a
one-nothing lead
one-nothing braves here in the top of
the second inning one-on-two outs for
the pirates
and the one-two on the way swung on and
missed
kevin smith bobbled it for a moment
picks up fires down to the bag anderson
wasn't even halfway down the line so
they easily secure the strikeout big
night for dansby last night three hits
including a homer
and he jumps all over the first pitch
and hammers that down the left field
line that's gonna be an extra base hit
camo gets to it quickly but not fast
enough for swanson who's now four for
five in the series jeff that's his ninth
double he was five for his last eight
coming into this game it was amazing
when i was down there chip
before the game catching that pitch
talked to dansby for a second you could
you could tell the energy back in him
would be great to see him tee off he's
hit one grand slam and has a 429
lifetime average with the bases loaded
3-2 count here it is it's lifted toward
right field
polanco going back he's going to turn
that ball is gone opposite field grand
slam for ronald lacuna jr
the bottom of the order feeds the top
and alumni weekend off to a grand start
and to his part the power by ronald
opposite field
with that home run acuna is tied shoei
otani of the angels for the big league
lead so a full count for the braves
third sacker austin reilly with one out
and here it is
and a shot into left center field that's
a base hit maybe more riley around first
he's on his way to second
how about that approach end result he
was down two strikes in a blink of an
eye
and he earns a double with one out
anderson
finally gets kevin smith
and through three it's
five nothing atlanta
[Music]
two strikes for polanco ian anderson
rolling along looking for his fourth win
you know out for the next couple months
with a broken hand but a swing and a
miss there's a curveball this time and
polanco didn't get it he strikes out
again that's number two tonight
as this one is rolled slowly riley was
the man in the shift and he'll make the
flip to first close play and they got
him
austin reilly playing the rover spot in
right field takes care of vargas and ian
anderson has set down seven consecutive
pirates
have now hit a homer in 14 straight
games as this one is rocketed down the
left field line fair haredia serves that
one to left it hits off the
stands and bounces back
into fair ground
so heredi is two for two tonight the
braves jeff are picking up hits and
bunches tonight and so acuna has a
chance to add to his 29 rbi total
high towering fly ball to left
camel going back but the park is gonna
hold it
there's the crab tagging is heredia he's
gonna come home it's a five rbi night
for acuna he wanted more but he's happy
to help out the braves who add on it's
six to nothing so the pirates have four
hits all of them are singles
the pitch
is swung and missed camel didn't get a
change up and that is strikeout number
four for anderson 02
punt still on and didn't get it slams
the bat down tomahawked it on top of the
plate
and tyler anderson strikes out for the
second time to her out i think that had
more to do with pitching than it did is
hitting
trying to bunt right there that's just
frustration and ozzy all these is the
battery broken over 16 with a first
inning run scoring double this ball has
cracked toward the gap and left center
field that's got carried to it
ball is gonna sail out of here
ozzy albee's has a couple of extra base
hits and the braves are pouring it on
on two-run homer makes it eight nothing
now riley unloads if he kept that fair
that's in the terrace hey dan a mammoth
home run so the braves with back-to-back
homers for the second time this year
and atlanta is pouring it on they are
taking out some
offensive frustrations on the pirates in
game two it's nine to nothing
newman reynolds and polanco do up
against ian anderson bounce back to him
and nice play didn't even know he had it
ian kind of reached across his body and
speared that on one hop
and able to throw him out one away
two and two
to brian reynolds swinging a miss struck
him out strikeout number six
for ian
marcelo zuma's over two with a walk he
scored a run two balls two strikes swing
and a drive that's hit toward the left
field corner did it stay high enough it
did
ozuna snaps the selfie and the braves
have scored 10 times tonight and marcel
joins the hit party three great crowds
expected this weekend tonight in atlanta
austin riley is the batter and he hits
this one a mile high toward left center
field out by that 385 side that one's
going to carry out
bombs away in atlanta g8 tonight
that's the fifth atlanta homer
riley's got two of them he's got three
extra base hits partnered here he comes
as this ball is crushed that's headed
towards center that ball is gone
the braves have gone back to back twice
tonight
and if hitting is contagious there's a
big-time outbreak at truest park in the
atlanta dugout here's a position player
wilmer defoe
pitching for the pirates eddie adrianza
is going to come on and swing the bat
this ball is hammered to right field
that's going to clear him first pitch
grand slam
grays have been two grand slams in this
game it's
19 nothing